يشير الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يشير الان
الى مقتل جندي الثالث في هذا الاشتباك
المسلح عند الحدود مع مصر اذا الحصيله
ارتفعت الى مقتل ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين في
هذا الاشتباك المسلح عند الحدود مع مصر في
معبر العوجه في الساعه الرابعه فجر هذا
اليوم
نتحدث عن بيان رسمي مقتل جندي ثالث وهنالك
ايضا اصابه ضابط صف بجراح طفيفه بمعنى
نتحدث الان عن ثلاثه قتله واصابه ضابط اخر
وهذا كما ذكرت يعني هو مؤشر الى خطوره هذه
العمليه ثلاثه
على هذا المستوى كذلك ما هي دلالاته
شاهدنا المروحيات
والانتشار ايضا على الحدود العسكري على
الحدود ما الذي يشير اليه ذلك ما دلالات
استمرار عمليات التنشيط وهذا الاستغفار
بهذا المستوى
عمليه التنشيط الان بالاساس بين الطرف
الاسرائيلي لفحصنا اذا كانت عمليه التسلل
هي مرتبطه فقط بشخص واحد اذا كان شرطي او
غير شرطي وهو الذي اطلق النار اما ان
هنالك اخرين نجحوا في التسلل في ساعات
الليل وبعتقد ان هذا جزء من عمليه التنشيط
طبعا المروحيات التي تظهر في الافق وهي
يعني عمليه تنشيط ظاهره هنالك ربما ايضا
قوات نقل القوات من منطقه الى منطقه
بالاضافه الى نقل اذا كان الحديث ايضا عن
مصابين بالتالي من الصعب التكهن الى ولكن
واضح ان هنالك عمليه تمشيط تتم اذا من
خلال قوات راجله وايضا من خلال طائرات
مروحيه وقد تكون ايضا وسائل تكنولوجيه
اخرى دخلت على الخاص في الساعات الاخيره
ولكن كما ذكرت كل هذا الامر بحاجه ايضا
الى تنسيق مع الطرف الاخر بمعنى انه منطقه
الحدود الان تشهد واضح انها تشهد تمشيط
وتمشيط على مستوى عالي اذا داخل الاراضي
الايطاليه للتاكد انها لا توجد عمليات
تصريحات للمسؤولين الاسرائيليين خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه التي تطرقت الى الحدود
الشماليه ذكروا هذا الحدث بانه شكل نوع من
تغيير قواعد اللعبه لدرجه ان البعض ذهب
الى سيناريو المواجهه وهذا ما تابعناه
عندما يعني دعينا اوصف المشهد وكان طبول
الحرب قرعت في منطقه الشمال قبل عده ايام
حتى عاده
التي بدات تصدر تباعا منذ بدء تكشف حدوث
هذه العمليه ربما بدات تلك البيانات
بيانات الجيش تصدر ساعات طويله بعد بدء
هذه العمليه التي انطلقت كما اشير في
المعلومات في الرابعه فجرا وصولا الى اخر
بيان يتحدث فيه عن ارتفاع الحصيله الى
ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين قتلوا في هذا
الاشتباك المسلح في معبر العوجه كيف ترى
ربما وتيره صدور هذه البيانات هل من
الطبيعي ان تكون بهذا الق در فقط وبهذا
القدر فقط من المعلومات
نعم نعم يعني اعتقد اليه العمل بالنسبه
للجيش الاسرائيلي والرقابه العسكريه ياليه
معروفه تبدا ببعض المعلومات الاوليه بعد
ذلك تتطور الى بيانات رسميه قصيره بدعمها
ببرقيات ولكن الجزئيه هنا يعني الامر
مرتبطرين اولا عندما يتم الحديث عن مقتل
الجنود هنالك دائما اهتمام اسرائيلي ان لا
تصل المعلومه لذوي الجنود ولعائلاتهم من
خلال الشبكات غير الرسميه وانما التاكيد
على وصول المعلومه للعائلات بشكل رسمي من
قبل الجهات المختصه داخل المؤسسه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه بعد تبليغ العائلات في
دوائرها المختلفه يصدر البيان الاول الذي
يتحدث ويعترف مثلا بمقتل جنود بعد ذلك
تبدا المعلومات التي ترشح بدعم من مكتب
رئيس الحكومه وصولا الى وزير الامن بعد
ذلك قياده الاركان والمنطق العسكري بمعنى
هذه الاليه العمل يعني هي معروفه ليست
مفاجئه اقول لك طبعا هنالك الكثير من
التحديات التي
لكن سيد جاكي خوري الاشاره فقط في هذه
البيانات والتاكيد على القتل في صفوف
الجنود الاسرائيليين بينما جرى الحديث فقط
عن مطلق النار وعن قتله في واحد من هذه
البيانات دون الاشاره الى تفاصيل اخرى وما
ذكر عن ارتدائه زين للشرطه المصريه او
لكونه مصري الجنسيه ورد عبر وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه